late in the third early in the fourth  and really helped him get back in the  ball game they have decided that whoever  wins the tip but in this case Toronto  they are going to let the shot clock to  run out because of the number 24 to  honor Kobe Bryant for free  his frontman bleep holding on to it and  the crowd recognizing  what this one  Charlotte these guys I don't know you  tell me  you top for me in this situation we've  been told the NBA is planning or has  canceled some of the games this evening  and the Joe Joe Murray will be the same  24-second shot clock of course Toby  Wyatt  of the 24  [Applause]  recognize that we chanting Cody and now  the game will actually begin